er ist jetzt bei uns der
Politikwissenschaftler der RAND
Corporation hallo schön dass Sie bei uns
sind her
SH thanks ja vielen Dank dass ich dabei
sein darf wir haben eben gerade in dem
Beitrag noch mal die Präsidenten der
Ukraine und Russlands gehört die Zeichen
stehen nach diesen Aussagen wirklich
absolut nicht für Verhandlung was bringt
sie trotzdem dazu dass sie glauben eine
solche Forderung wäre
[Musik]
umsetzbar
ich kann natürlich nicht vorher sagen
dass es kurzfristig Gespräche geben wird
im Moment ist es so dass die Politik in
der
Ukraine und in den westlichen Ländern
die Politik geht nicht die Richtung das
gleiche gilt für Russland aber ich denke
dass es fair ist in einem Zusammenhang
wo keine Seite in der Position ist eine
absolute einen absoluten militärischen
Gewinn davon zu tragen da ist die
Alternative zu so einem solchen SEG ein
verhandeltes
konfliktende irgendwann wird das
passiert die Frage ist wann und unter
welchen
Bedingungen in einem Artikel des
deutschen Nachrichtenmagazins der
Spiegel vom Dezember ist von einem
hintergrundtreffen beim deutschen
Botschafter in Washington die Rede an
dem unter anderem auch sie und der Chef
des Bundeskanzleramts Wolfgang Schmidt
teilgenommen haben sollen wobei wir
wissen öffentlich darf man von solchen
Hintergrund treffen also gar nichts
berichten sie dürfen da gar nicht drüber
sprechen wenn es denn so gewesen sein
soll nichtsdestotrotz eine Frage an Sie
können Sie uns denn sagen ob über solch
konkrete Szenarien für ein Ende des
russischen angriffskriegs in
politikreisen in den USA wo es
öffentlich immer heißt darüber
entscheidet nur die Ukraine wird darüber
irgendwie diskutiert in diesem
politikkreisen oder
nachgedacht
na ich kann natürlich nicht das
Ansprechen was in einem privaten
Gespräch diskutiert wurde das ist
natürlich jetzt nicht für die
Öffentlichkeit bestimmt ich würde
sagen es stimmt überein mit der Position
der amerikanischen Regierung seit dem
Anfang des
Krieges irgendwann wird der Krieg
nämlich in einer Verhandlungslösung Ende
die Frage ist wann und unter welchen
Bedingungen
und verschiedene Leute haben dazu
natürlich verschiedene Ansichten was
normal ist aber man kann sicherlich
sagen aus moralischer Perspektive und
praktischer Perspektive ist es so dass
die
Ukrainer
natürlich diesen Prozess auch selbst
voll unterstützen müssten also praktisch
gesehen der Gedanke von Verhandlungen
oder Abkommen ohne der Unterstützung
wäre eigentlich nicht durchführbar denn
die Ukrainer müssen ja Teil der Lösung
sein anderen seit sind diejenigen die
kämpfen und sterben und Sie müssen
natürlich das dabei das Sagen haben und
das wird dann bestimmend sein das heißt
natürlich nicht dass Parteien von außen
also z.B die Partner der Ukraine dass
die nicht Ratschläge geben können oder
ihre eigene Perspektive haben könnten
wie sich dieser Konflikt
weiterentwickeln mag und
was auch ihre eigenen Interessen angeht
in die weitere Entwicklung dieses
Krieges ein User bei uns im Stream Lukas
der fragt sich wie soll man mit diesem
Kriegstreiber Putin verhandeln er will
doch nur die Ukraine erobern weil sie
keinen prorussischen Präsidenten mehr
hat und mehr nicht also die Frage an Sie
wie soll man mit jemand wie Putin
verhandeln der 2014 völkerrechtswidrig
die Krim annektiert hat und der dann
auch die die Hände ausgestreckt hat nach
dem gesamten Gebiet der Ukraine wie soll
das gehen
ich denke ihr Zuschauer hat da was
wichtiges gesagt das ursprüngliche Ziel
von Putin bei der Invasion im
Februar 2022 war ein Regimewechsel und
er hat's nicht geschafft und seither
haben sich seine Ziele verändert die
sind jetzt ziemlich unklar eigentlich
und er will da jetzt wenn er darüber
spricht über seine Ziele auch nicht so
spezifisch werden aber letztlich hat er
gezeigt dass er wähens ist und bereit
ist Abkommen zu verletzen wann immer es
ihm gefällt aber wir wissen ja nicht wer
in Russland die Führung hat Russland ist
ja der Aggressor
der Kriegstreiber in diesem Krieg und
daher ist es so dass jede Verhandlung
über ein Ende des Krieges auch Russland
involvieren
muss wenn wir uns unsere Gegner selber
aussuchen könnten wäre das natürlich
toll aber so ist es eben nicht der
Westen macht ganz klar über Verhandlung
entscheidet die Ukraine was müsste denn
ihrer Meinung nach getan werden dass die
Ukraine denn überhaupt für sowas bereit
wäre wie soll das
gehen so
ich denke die westlichen
Regierungen sollten in der Position sein
diese Frage mit der Ukraine zu
diskutieren es wäre schlecht für alle
wenn sie irgendwann an den
Verhandlungstisch gehen und nicht
vorbereitet sind Vorbereitung ist
wichtig selbst wenn die Zeit jetzt noch
nicht bereit ist um formelle
Verhandlungen zu starten und jetzt ganz
klar ist nicht die richtige Zeit aber es
ist die richtige Zeit um sich
vorzubereiten für diesen Moment und ich
denke wir müssen mit diesen Gesprächen
jetzt anfangen selbst wenn der Prozess
vielleicht erst in 6 oder 12 Monaten
oder egal wie lange es noch dauert
beginnen kann und das wäre der erste
Schritt um
anzufangen wenn es sich zeigt dass man
kein Abkommen mit dieser russischen
Regierung bekommen kann dann haben wir
immer noch die Option
weiterzukämpfen das setzt voraus dass
man aufhört zu kämpfen um anfangen um
anzufangen zu sprechen aber die meisten
Konflikte wurden gelöst das wären beide
Parteien gleichzeitig kämpfen und
Sprachen statt dass man erst aufhörte zu
kämpfen und dann anfingt zu sprechen ich
glaube so wie das hier auch sein die
Russen und die Ukrainer sprechen ja sie
sprechen einfach nicht über das
Ausstiegsszenario jetzt sprechen sie in
Verhandlungen über den Austausch von
kriegsgef angenen und das sehen wir ja
schon während der ganzen Dauer des
Konfliktes hat immer wieder gegeben und
noch mal aber ganz konkret die Frage
sehen Sie keine Gefahr dass Putin nicht
auch wieder angreifen könnte wenn man
mit ihm verhandelt und es dann dazu
kommen sollte dass eben Gebiete der
Ukraine nicht zurückgewonnen gewer nicht
zurückgewonnen werden können dass Putin
dann also wieder die gesamte Ukraine
angreift oder vielleicht sogar noch mehr
noch weitere Länder angreift was soll
das Zeichen an ihn sein dass er das
nicht tut was soll das Versprechen sein
dass er das nicht
tätte also ich denke egal wo die
Konfliktlinie ist selbst wenn die
Ukraine all sein international
anerkanntes Territorium wieder erleint
wird es immer noch das Risiko geben dass
Russland wieder angreift Russland wird
eine potenzielle Bedrohung für Ukraine
und die anderen Nachbarn sein egal wie
der Krieg endet ich glaube nicht dass
Russland demilitarisiert wird das wohl
kaum und das ist nur mal eine Tatsache
mit der wir zurechtkmen müssen
langfristig was für ein Signal ja
entschuldigung ich habe sie unterbrochen
durch unsere zeitliche Verzögerung das
tut mir sehr leid wollen sie den Satz
noch zu Ende führen
wir brauchen einfach
konkrete Zusicherungen dass das nicht
noch mal passiert z.B eine Reihe von
Anreizen die man schaffen könnte um das
Waffenstillstandsabkommen weiter
durchzuführen vielleicht unter
Bedingungen
eine eine Befreiung von Sanktionen oder
dass es negative Sanktion gibt wenn das
Waffenstillstandsabkommen verletzt wird
es gibt keine Situation wo man völlig
die Möglichkeit nehmen kann nicht das
waffenstilstandsabkommen zu verletzen er
muss es auch Willen es muss bestimmte
Anreize und Bestrafungen geben um ihn
dazu zu
bringen aber sagen wir es gibt also
diesen Waffenstillstand es gibt
Verhandlung aber es bedeutet für die
Ukraine sie verliert dabei Teil ihres
Territoriums was für ein Signal sendet
das aus auch an andere Länder z.B an
China im Bezug auf Taiwan um jetzt ein
Beispiel zu nennen was sendet das aus
wenn die nkarter für territoriale
Integrität also zum Schutz der
Unverletzlichkeit des staatlichen
Hoheitsgebiets wenn die dann nichts
zählt der chinavgleich funktioniert hier
nicht denn die Vereinigten Staaten
Deutschland und die meisten anderen
Länder Welt sehen Taiwan ja formell
als souveränes chinesisches Territorium
an es gibt ein allgemeines Verständnis
dass Taiwan sich in diesem Zusammenhang
selber
regiert rechtlich
gesehen wird die Ukraine und die
westlichen Partner die werden keine
russische Okkupation
ukrainischen Hoheitsgebietes als legitim
ansehen können ähm
Russland beschuldigen dass sie
ukrainisches hohitsgebiet
besetzt
hält die Republik
Südkorea geht auch davon aus dass die
Souveränität über ganz Korea hat wir
haben nie die russische Annektion von
der Krim 2014 anerkannt das sind große
Verletzungen der un-karter
und dafür muss jemand die Verantwortung
übernehmen aber ich sehe keine Kaskade
von
ähnlichen Verletzungen die daraus
entstehen weil die westlichen Partner
der Ukraine ja
zusammenarbeiten um signifikante Kosten
Russland aufzubürden wegen der
Aggression Russlands das Wichtige dabei
ist dass es einfach unattraktiv sein
muss für Russland so zu handeln
und ich kann mir keinen chinesischen
Führer oder zukünftigen russischen
Führer vorstellen der nach dem 22 nach
dem Februar 22 sag das war eine tolle
Idee das machen wir noch
mal es gibt Fragen noch an Sie hier bei
uns im Stream von Zuschauerinnen und
Zuschauern und zwar gibt es hier eine
Frage ganz konkret von einem User der
fragt sie direkt was würden Sie machen
wenn Sie an der Stelle von Herrn
selenski wären also in seinen Schuhen
wären
das tan das ist eine schwierige
Frage ich denke
mal ich könnte mir vorstellen dass ich
versuchen
würde die öffentlichen Erwartungen zu
managen ich glaube diese Erwartungen
sind erhöht worden über die letzten
Monate
und ich glaube
eine Milderung dieser Erwartung und eine
Reduzierung der Erwartungen sodass die
Erwartungen
übereinstimmen mit dem kriegsfortschritt
W der letzten ne Monate das würde zu
Möglichkeiten führen wo man in Zukunft
sich mehr Flexibilität schafft das
könnte eine potenzielle Handlungsweise
sein die ich vorschlagen könnte aber wie
gesagt das ist natürlich eine schwierige
Position der ist aus verschiedensten
Gründen und es ist natürlich schwierig
sich in seine Position zu versetzen und
für ihn zu sprechen und zuletzt noch
eine weitere Frage an Sie aus dem Stream
wie verhandeln wenn die Gegenseite also
Russland nicht verhandeln will bzw die
Vorstellung einer Kapitulation gleich
kommen
Russland wird die Kapitulation der
Ukraine sicherlich nicht bekommen wenn
sie unrealistische Forderungen stellen
dann haben wir immer noch die
Möglichkeit zu sagen okay wir hören mit
den Verhandlungen auf und die Ukraine
haben auch diese Chance
Verhandlungen zählen ja nicht darauf ab
dass man seine eigene Kapitulation
anbietet man versucht das gleiche
erreichen was man auf dem Schlachtfeld
versucht zu erreichen aber in einem
anderen Bereich das ist einfach eine
andere Art und Weise seine nationalen
Interessen zu erreichen das gilt für die
Ukraine für den Westen und eben auch für
Russland ich denke wir können erwarten
dass da hart verhandelt wird aber die
Kapitulation der Ukraine ist nicht auf
dem Tisch und sollte das auch nicht sein
und wenn Russland nicht ernsthaft
verhandeln will dann verlieren wir
nichts dadurch dass wir mal
ausprobieren die Einschätzung das
Politikberater Samuel ch vielen Dank
dass Sie heute mit ihrer Sicht bei uns
in der Sendung waren danke
ihnen ich danke ihnen vielen Dank